so i think cbs is on a roll by the way
when it comes to concerts listen to this
actress kerry washington is perhaps best
known for playing crisis management
expert olivia pope
on the hit series scandal now on that
show she played a badass off camera she
is a badass now she's teaming up with
singer alicia keys and actress america
ferreira
to host tonight's cbs special every vote
counts
it's a celebration of democracy this
non-partisan event will celebrate the
power of voting
it will feature appearances from a
number of stars like
chris rock jennifer lopez leonardo
dicaprio kelly clarkson and lin-manuel
miranda
of course kerry washington joins us now
she'll be participating hey kerry
washington look at you
so you say you want to remind people
because i love the lineup by the way you
said you want to remind people
when it comes to voting what really this
night is about
celebrating the voter right like this is
a time when people have a lot of anxiety
and stress about the upcoming election
so
alicia keys and america ferrara and i we
just wanted to create an atmosphere of
hope and love and celebration because it
actually is this
wonderful joy that we get to vote
yeah and i said and you want to create
fun too when it comes to voting yeah
and fun that's right and also i think
there's a lot of focus on the candidates
right now
and some people are passionate about the
candidates i am passionate about
some of the candidates yes but we wanted
to make sure that the passion
tonight was centered around the voter
like you
some people are feeling really excited
about candidates some people aren't
the point is you need to be excited
about you and your family and your
community and your city and your state
you can impact real change in this
country and
in your life so getting excited about
you
the viewer and your power that's what
tonight is all about it's really a
celebration of
all americans and the ability that we
have to be part of change
you know what what i like about it is
that we the people really mean
something carrie and that's what i think
when i think about the the the program
that you're
you're involved in tonight it's we the
people that make the difference and i
think sometimes people forget that
i want to talk about voting i went to
vote yesterday the line they said would
have been two and a half hours if i'd
gotten at the end
so i decided i'm going to go home and
come back with the chair so i'm going to
try it again on friday or saturday
because i'm definitely going to vote
so most people see long lines and they
get very excited because they think
yes people are enthusiastic it's time to
go you look at the long lines and you
say it's a sign of voter suppression
what does that mean what do you mean by
that
well to me you know there's a lot of
research that says that
nobody should be standing in line to
vote more than 30 minutes but in a
functioning democracy
voting should not be a huge challenge
but unfortunately in a lot of
communities in a lot of neighborhoods
it is there are long lines um that's
another reason why we wanted to make
this special tonight because
it may not always be easy and simple but
it's so
important and it can be fun people are
sending pizza to the polls
you can meet people in the polls it's
safe to go if you wear a mask
and you keep your social distancing we
just wanted to create some
relief around voting because listen
there are a lot of things you may want
to change about
how easy or difficult it is to vote but
the best way to do that
is to vote yeah like you have to
participate
and and remember that basically voting
means that we're the boss
right when we pay our taxes we pay our
elected officials salaries
and so they work for us but when we
don't
show up and vote it's like we're asleep
at the job we're not bossing up
voting is our opportunity to like
express our voice express our values
say who we are and what we want our
country to be and um
and we just we really wanted to have a
night to remind people about that
carrie you make that case so well i mean
the american people are the boss
uh our vote does count uh we're in
charge i mean the the white house the
most powerful office in the land
we decide who goes into that office so
why
do so few people who have the
opportunity to vote do so i think we're
about just over 50
compared to our peers out there in the
world our participation rate in our
democracy is very low
why well again that's one of the reasons
why we really wanted to to do this
special because actually this year
people are voting in record
historic numbers right 76 million people
already have voted early
already yeah that's that's a reason to
party that is a reason to celebrate and
listen i know we like to go come forward
and say like here are all the big stars
leo dicaprio and jennifer lopez all of
those folks are in the special but one
of the things
i'm so excited about is that the special
is filled with
just americans like everyday americans
folks who are voting for the for the
first time
um we have that did you guys see that
clip of the amazing woman b
she's over 100 years old she went to
vote covered yes
we ran that story she's on the special
yeah i get to interview
her along with some other first-time
voters we have you know people working
out in the field to register voters we
just have
like people who are participating in
this democracy it's really to celebrate
them i can't wait i can't wait to see it
carrie i want to
ask you one olivia pope question before
you go because olivia pope became a verb
when people said she's the olivia pope
of fill in the blank of whatever
business they were talking about
do you miss her i know you've moved on
to other things and you're doing very
well but where does she stand with you
because you really
became an iconic figure in tv land
amanda
oh you're so sweet to ask i you know i
i don't miss her i've been thinking
about her a lot lately though because i
was laughing with some friends that
when i read the first episode of scandal
and i i just fell in love with this
character she's so aspirational and
powerful she's so badass i don't know if
you can say that in the morning but she
is
and um and i and i knew that she was
flawed that she was sleeping with a
married man but i still thought i want
to be this woman right on television
and the episode that broke me that made
me cry about her
was when she stole the election oh yes
that was the moment
i remember that no yes and i thought
what an interesting
thing to learn about myself and it
points me toward my values that it was
so
important to me that she be you know in
defense of a free
and fair just election which i think
there's something that really lines up
for that with me and
so you know when i think about the
special tonight it's not only that every
vote counts but also that we have to
count every vote
and even when we're not feeling like
maybe
like we can have full confidence in our
systems we can have full confidence in
each other
all right carrie we're going to have to
leave it there and no stealing elections
here
thank you very much thank you for taking
the time and getting up early we really
really appreciate that
you can watch every vote counts a
celebration of democracy tonight at 9 8
central right here on cbs
and streaming live on cbs all access